BACK IN JUNE.
AND NEITHER ONE WANTS
DYLAN COZENS GETS IT ON GOAL.
AND UP ICE, BLUEGER, STEPS IN,
WALK THE LINE.
DROPS IT OVER TO CROSBY.
THAT SHOT DOESN'T CLEANLY GET
THROUGH ABOUT YOU HE'SO GO IN T
CHANCE, HERE TO GO UP HIGH TO
TOKARSKI OUT OF THE REACH OF NE.
HIS PANTS, HIS WORK.   IS THE P
AND DUSTI
OF JAR MILLER TIME AND TIME
AGAIN AND JARRY IS SCREENED BY
HIS OWN PLAYERDRAG, AND
STOPPED BY TOKARSKI.
>>HORTHANDED
ACTION WHEN HE WAS WITH THE CANA
HOW ABOUT THAT TIP FROM OF THE
BEAUTIFUL REDIRECTION, HE'S  AT
CARTER COULDN'T GET IT BLOCKED !
WASN'T SURE WHERE IT WAS, THEY
CAN SEE.
>> NO, IT'S
ANDLED THEM OVER AND ON GOAL
AND HAND
AND CAUGHT
FRONT, AND AGAIN, AND DENIED BY
TOKARSKI. GUENTZEL, SAYS THANK
VERY MUCH, POWER PLAY GOAL THATE
WAY T CARTER DENIED
FRONT OF THE NET AND SKINNER NOT
ABLE TO GETIS,
TOKARSKI.
AND THEN, THAT SIMON LINE HAD A
AND SHUT DOWN
AND JUST ONTO TAGE THOMPSON'S O
SHOT?
NOW, THE PENGUINS WANT IT TO BE
PENALTHIGH.
RODRIGUES, SHOOTS RIGHT THERE.
TOKAKI MRSAKES A HE'S BEEN THER
EVERY OPPORTUNITY.